-Our next guest
is a 10-time Grammy winner
and Country Music Hall of Famer.
This is his new book here,
"Willie Nelson's
Letters to America,"
which comes out June 29th.
Here is the one and only
Willie Nelson.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what
I'm talking about.
Looking great, buddy.
Willie, I love you.
Welcome back, pal.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
It's good to be back.
-In August,
you're about to kick off
the Outlaw Music Festival Tour.
You're back on tour.
Are you excited?
-Yeah, I'm glad to,
you know, get back out.
It's been over a year now,
and I'm not sure I can remember
"Whiskey River."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Well, of course, the first thing
that a lot of people think of
when they think of you going on
tour is "On the Road Again."
And I didn't want to do that.
It could be too corny.
But, I do love that,
and we all love you singing
"On the Road Again."
Do you remember writing
"On the Road Again"
and where did that come from?
-Yeah, I was on an airplane
with Sydney Pollack
and Jerry Schatzberg,
the director of and producer
of the "Honeysuckle Rose" movie.
-Yeah.
-And they were trying
to think of a song
that might go with the movie.
And I said, "Well, what do you
want the song to be like,
or what do you want it to say?"
And they said, "Well, something
about being on the road."
And I said, "Well,
what about on the road again,
I can't wait to get
on the road again,
the life I love
is making music with my friends,
I can't wait
to get on the road again --
Is that alright?"
And they said,
"I think so, yeah."
-[ Laughs ]
"That's exactly it. Yes.
Did we record that?
Yes, that's it.
Do it three more times,
we got a song."
Happy birthday, by the way.
I know you're --
You're 88, is that correct?
-88.
[ Cheers and applause ]
88.
♪♪
-Is there a secret
that keeps you going strong?
-Oh, I think, you know, you got
to keep a positive attitude.
I believe that.
I always have believed that.
In fact, I wrote a new song
the other day --
"Imagine what you want,
and then get out of the way."
And I think the most important
line is "get out of the way."
-Yeah, like -- I like that.
[ Applause ]
Imagine --
Were you always into that,
like, into visualization
or visualizing your future?
-Yeah.
Maybe I did it a long time
without realizing
what I was doing.
But someone told me
one time that --
this was the
Norman Vincent Peale, I think,
and some of those guys
he talked about --
Power of positive thinking.
And I began to realize
that there was
a lot of truth in that.
-Yeah. During this time
that we all stayed in at home
and didn't leave,
not only did you
write a great book,
but you also did a duet
with Barbra Streisand.
-Yeah.
-I loved it, by the way.
I can't believe you guys
have never sang together.
-Well, matter of fact, we did --
Years ago, we did a song.
It never came out.
But then she asked me
to do this one.
And, you know, she's always been
one of my favorite people,
a great singer.
We had a lot of fun
hanging out with her
back when they were doing
"A Star is Born"
with Kris Kristofferson.
-Wow.
-And, you know,
we became good friends,
so I was glad
to be able to sing with her.
She's -- She's a great singer,
and one of my desires
was to do a duet with Barbra.
-Yeah, it's fantastic.
And her record
comes out pretty soon.
But she'll be
on the show for that.
I got to say, reading this book,
it's like hanging out with you,
what I believe would be
hanging out with you.
You don't allow me
to hang out with you. But --
[ Laughter ]
But if I could,
I'd bet it would be like this.
I just want to read
just the first sentence of this.
The introduction's like,
"Dear readers,
thank you for picking up a copy
of my new book,
a collection of fond memories,
personal letters,
good songs, and bad jokes."
[ Laughter ]
That is exactly the vibe,
and it is so cool and so funny
and so interesting.
You go into --
You do tell jokes in here.
You go into some snippets
of songs that you're writing,
brand-new songs
that you're writing.
What made you
want to write this?
-Oh, I don't know. Somebody
said something about money.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
[ Both laugh ]
Really, I thought
it was a good idea,
and Turk Pipkin and I --
the writer
who helped me with the book,
a great friend of mine,
and we've done, you know, a lot
of things together in the past.
So I had a lot of fun doing it.
-Well, next time
I see you in-person,
I would love for you
to sign my copy,
'cause I'm going to read it
every single day
until I see you.
-I would.
-Willie Nelson, everybody.
His book "Letters to America,"
comes out June 29th.